according to the World Economic Forum
the most talked-about people at this
year's meeting were Greta tunberg and
Donald Trump from and tunberg polar
opposites in a new wave of discourse
that seems to have come into its own
here this week about climate change
about the environment even about the old
ways of capitalist thinking that have
always seemed so at home here we must
remember that as long as we do not treat
this crisis as a crisis and as long as
the facts and the science are being left
completely ignored then we will not be
able to solve this crisis world leaders
and CEOs many of them are responding
with one in particular the billionaire
founder of cloud computing giant
Salesforce Marc Benioff declaring
capitalism dead this obsession that we
have with maximizing profits for
shareholders alone has led to incredible
inequality and a planetary emergency but
among the banking giants some like
Citibank and Goldman Sachs pushed back
against calls by climate activists to
stop funding the biggest polluters that
after Greenpeace called out a number of
banks represented at Davos for having
lent 1.4 trillion dollars to fossil fuel
producers since the Paris climate Accord
was signed in 2015 so how much of it is
hypocrisy a green cloak of virtue behind
which old fashioned deals are still
being done on climate there are
meaningful moves by some private sector
leaders that will actually make a
difference not only in terms of what
they do but will actually force others
competitors in their sectors to not be
left behind so yes I find that
meaningful but if you asked me is the
deal-making changing is capitalism dead
frankly in a world where the economy is
getting a little softer they're focusing
more on their bottom lines
this year's Davos has witnessed a
confrontation between the
decision-makers and the young who will
have to live with those decisions
[Music]
they may not be winning yet but their
impact is growing
Jonah hole al-jazeera in the Swiss Alps